bonsoir gmail on a voulu vous réinviter
entendre votre témoignage en d'y être
parce qu'on a tourné ce sujet il y a
quelques semaines déjà pour prendre des
nouvelles de cette famille parce que
c'est vrai que ça semble entourer
d'absurdité et surtout beaucoup de
misère à 8 dans une caravane est ce qu
ils vivent toujours au même endroit où
vous leur avez trouvé un endroit pour
confortable
alors ils vivent toujours au même
endroit la difficulté qu'on a eu ça a
été que le petit bébé qui était
prématuré qui en difficultés sanitaires
de santé il a fallu qu'on compare en
mieux et je salue d'ailleurs
réhabilitant les activistes du dadt 49
de la grande ourse et basson de 49 qui
ont permis à ce que ce petit bibi qui
est sorti de l'hôpital soit dans un
endroit qui soit un peu plus chaud plus
confortable que dans un endroit où les
femmes la famille vit actuellement c'est
à dire toujours sur une passe de cartes
de parking et dans une carafe il fait 3
fois d'ailleurs la nuit et y les
bouteilles de gaz effectivement son ce
vide très facilement et vous vous dites
dans le sujet on doit chasser du pauvre
vous vous parlez de violence
institutionnelle
expliquez vous ce que vous voulez dire
bah oui ce que je dis c'est que
effectivement on va des services qui
sont très actifs pour essayer de trouver
où se trouvent des personnes en fin ou
sont des personnes qui essaient de
survivre à la rue et on a surtout d'un
positionnement qui est un positionnement
pour moi politique que ce soit de
l'institution municipale ou d'autres
institutions comme l'office public hlm
qui doit considérer qu'on a envoyé un
message vous aviez un sujet justement
sur un réfugié ont l' ange et un
positionnement une rhétorique qui pour
nous est complètement stupide qui est de
d'éviter l'appel d'air et donc pour
éviter l'appel des actes des gens
arrivent sur le territoire on ne fait
rien de mieux qu essayer de rendre la
situation très inconfortable de ceux qui
essayent déjà de survivre à la rue et de
ceux qui vivent dans la misère et en
cela on va pas hésiter comme l'office
public hlm qui est considéré
actuellement notamment peau des n'y a
non seulement assigné en référé c'est à
dire en urgence une famille qui sont
places de parking comme on l'a vu tout à
l'heure et de demander le recours à la
force publique pour l'expulsion en cela
il n'y a pas de n'y a pas d'urgence pour
t'en prends propriétaire pour pouvoir
essayer de demander à ce que
les personnes qui s'en s'ont petite
place qui est occupée soit sera donc
expulsé n'y a pas d'urgence n'y a pas
d'urgence et c'est ce qui est grave un
petit peu certaines espèces pas le temps
à tous les collectifs les associations
de pouvoir permettre à la famille de
s'inscrire aussi à vous de pouvoir faire
un garrot on sait très bien que les
délais sont très longs ça va jusqu'à
trois mois au pouvoir essayez de
disposer d'un hébergement ça peut aller
jusqu'à six mois dans le cas d'un dalot
pour essayer d'obtenir un logement en
l'occurrence la de la famille demander
un logement donc on est même pas le
temps aux personnes de se retourner et
en cela je dis que cette violence déjà
dans la misère que la famille subit
s'ajoute la violence institutionnelle
puisque on a vu parfois des policiers
essayé de déloger les personnes qui
étaient quittés en situation très
précaire donc en l'occurrence en mitri
de la loi et on a pardonné mois
maintenant on a compris en tout cas de
messages en mai nous sommes en campagne
présidentielle vous avez notamment sur
ce plateau qui vient de nous rejoindre
un port parle de xavier bertrand si vous
avez un message à passer au candidat
lequel
s
alors le message est simple soit il ment
arrêtez vos démagogie vous discours de
bla bla bla pour essayer de rassurer un
camp plus qu'un autre et favoriser un
groupe puisque nous c'est une violence
de classe qui est inacceptable on arrête
stop ont fait l'humanité et la
convention des droits de l'homme et à la
convention des droits de l'enfant on les
applique on est respectueux des
conventions internationales qui
permettent aux gens de retrouver un
petit peu plus de dignité voilà c'est le
seul message pour leur donner avec tous
les collectifs et autres associations
essayez de ne pas utiliser votre pouvoir
et vos moyens aussi cassé des gens alors
que ces gens là ont déjà subi plus que
pourrait subir la misère toute entière
de de l'humanité merci beaucoup djamel
blanchard un militant d'al 49 d'avoir
été avec nous il